you are fake dudes the level of
dishonesty is out of control information
that was false and I realized how nasty
and how fake the press can be very
effective Donald Trump's famous
catchphrase fake news has dominated the
headlines ever since he first uttered it
why does it drive his detractors so
crazy well some would argue that it's
true
false information and deceptive
reporting seems to be everywhere let's
review some of the fake news of 2018
well one of the most outrageous examples
was the cover of Time magazine it
depicted a sobbing toddler representing
Donald Trump's policy of separating
immigrant children from their parents
however it turns out that the girl in
the photograph was not separated from
her mother my daughter was not separated
from her mother but yeah she's the face
of this immigration problem she has
helped create awareness but let's go
through some other examples now folks
had a good laugh when it was revealed
that the Washington Post had actually
cited the satirical publication known as
clickhole when reporting on the fact
that British people were trying to make
the song American Idiot by Green Day go
through the charts when Donald Trump was
visiting the country and in other
instances we've seen journalists just
straight-up making things up
for example a reporter for the webzine
known as Mike claimed that Maria butanna
who's just pled guilty to charges of
being an unregistered lobbyist for
Russia was in a meeting at the Oval
Office I thought this was a Photoshop
but it's not this is marinwood tina
arrested for being a Russian spy in the
Oval Office with Trump turned out that
she was wrong the person in the
photograph was actually a National
Security Council staffer but in the
journalist defense they both do have red
hair and we all know that all of us
gingers look the same how about a paper
on canine rape culture in dog parks or a
feminist rewrite of Hitler's my struggle
it
turns out that this year fake news was
used to make a political point people
were submitting fake research
in order to expose what they believed
was a bias in academia some of the fake
research got through issues and one
trend we saw throughout the year was
fact checkers retracting their fact
checks what could be more embarrassing
those who claim they're stopping the
spreading of misinformation actually
spreading misinformation themselves and
admitting to it based on what we've seen
throughout the year it seems pretty
clear that fake news will be well alive
in 2019 Kaleb Maupin RT New York
you